temis en clair technopole micro
technique et scientifique ne s'essouffle
pas trois entreprises ont choisi cet
espace pour marquer une nouvelle étape
dans leur développement
pour elle c'est une identité un repère
qui les aimante
il y a quinze ans c'était des pâtures
avec des montbéliardes les moutons
quelques chevaux aujourd'hui c'est 122
mille mètres carrés d'industrie 25 me
nos projets donc métaux cent cinquante
mille mètres carrés et des milliers
d'emplois ici sur themis d'em rue ce
rôle d'aimant me convient bien créée en
1991 spécialisée dans la mécatronique
poli capte il est implanté sur la
technopole depuis l'été 2010 est la
société poly capte il fait du
développement donc en électronique sur
des projets sur des produits qui sont
donc très technique le fait d'être
implanté à temis est une identité
donc c'est c'est la marque de fabrique
il faut il faut être présents sur ce
lieu créée en 2012
usi j'ai pas choisi de centraliser son
activité ici à temis l'entreprise
conçoit et fabrique des pièces
métalliques de haute qualité pour
l'horlogerie et la joaillerie pour sa
part trendy créateur distributeur de
montres sous licence est venu asseoir sa
dynamique dans de nouveaux locaux pour
ses 20 ans d'existence on a plus d
espace sur la une logistique améliorer
puis on assure toi un confort aussi pour
nos salariés qui a complètement
différent l'entreprise est
bien évidemment développer sur le
secteur horloger en france et est un
petit peu aussi sur l'export avec un
portefeuille de marques avec tout un un
département de service après vente
autre bon signe la naissance d'une
nouvelle structure dédiée à
l'accompagnement de création
d'entreprises innovantes